how's it going red my name is Pierre or
back welcome back to some more bully I
have a surprise for your brothers today
aren't you happy about that took me
about 40 minutes to fix and it's been
something that you bros have not been
able to shut up about which I love and
yeah I'm one second and I'll go and get
it don't worry about it Oh all the over
LJ think that would work
holy [ __ ] shut up
alright alright there she is what does
he go don't you dare don't you deaf
don't touch hands don't you touch ah
[ __ ] off
oh you you're gonna get for this oh [ __ ]
wow wow wow
I gotta go cut breath [ __ ] fly like
crazy holy [ __ ] look at that hi there
ah [ __ ]
oh sorry sorry sorry
eyebrows it looks like we have to go to
class where school if I had one of these
I might I wouldn't mind I've actually
gone to school hopefully we'll get
something without a [ __ ] [ __ ] this
class are we all ready to cut something
open today that's nasty
hey there's nice tea uh-huh I love the
feeders in the background what Oh for
[ __ ] sake
all right let's just get this over with
really quick because this is just
[ __ ] it's disgusting
this gasps daughter as a great man once
said it was me take your time boy
shut up ssin is an art catching up a rat
is not art in my bag especially this
area [ __ ] sake man all right uh ah ah
well carefully oh that smells great is
this the penis is this a rat dick that
should not be on YouTube take your time
boy I do not want to take time for this
take your time section is an art how did
the first time really that that went
rather well you have a steady thing what
do I am good day I'm good
he has mark Jim Pat's mat hand hand here
what the [ __ ] is that
and the game crashed
I press next quest finally Jesus Christ
this has been a mess add a mess today
because I had to redo like old quest
yeah oh ha ha very funny
yeah I'm sorry did I hurt you ok ok yeah
Oh aha
now we're even I'm glad it's a job my
nose how you doing Clint me just fine Oh
what yeah I can tell the world yeah see
that you seem really balanced that's
what my shrink said
then I head-butted him like this oh okay
alright buddy don't you not uh really
true you're not gonna hit not show you
want to fight me because I really like
that come on I don't want to fight
we're friends you know that really then
give me a bike I want a bike or I wanna
fight all right I'll get you a bike
right here that makes sense yeah uh okay
we have to steal someone's bike
apparently ha
god damn it where's my mobile go-kart
motor bud card
what where the [ __ ] is it Clint
how many commenters you need seriously
all right this one is pretty close add
an S come back here yo that is cleanse
bike hey I'm taking this boy I'm sorry
then do it I can do it I just made his
dream come true he wanted to drive an
SUV I'll steal his fine
hey watch and I'll give you the money I
get money now I thought you could have
just bought a bike that I could this is
so dumb
okay there you go i what am i doing
another vice get lost and then steal at
what ah brother
oh that's supposed to be a poor victim
over here and it's gone
get off my foot - oh shut the cops
ha ha ha job laughs it don't bother with
this stuff kid
it's gonna ruin your life you're ruining
my life
because now I have to go all the [ __ ]
way over there goes through the
principal this better be [ __ ] good
let's uh kittens
now I'm not one to give in to popular
sentiment you can tell that by your
clothes just great
irelia as I said I am NOT a people
pleaser but in your case I'm going to
make an exception and exam cool yes you
are without a doubt the least popular
boy in the school right now even that
fat child who wets himself is more
popular than you Yahoo and mentally it
has also come to my attention that you
are a filthy dirty foul-mouthed awful
little vandal yeah we already knew that
very droll a comedian till the end well
you'll have to pursue your comedic
talents elsewhere boy am I getting
expelled worth is not for you
no honey you know what's funny you
you're a joke you old creep
you and your stuck-up lame-ass school
with its bullies it's sex pest teachers
this place is a dump
and you're a big nose freak the same
rewards losses and bullies I just stand
up to them you painted obscene graffiti
on the townhome no I was a man good
Authority it was you oh yeah then who
squealed tell me that a commendable
pupil did feel the need to tell her you
are responsible for this Alfred watch
Jerry Smith look I'm at that painting
about a town hall but that kid likes to
torture people Gary Smith is the next
head of this school he's responsible
courteous and not afraid of being an
unpopular leader you were blind old man
blind and you are leaving I tried to
contact your mother but she's still off
on a cruise until I hear from her I will
have to let you stay here in your room
but you may not wear the school uniform
r10 Clyde you are leaving the Academy to
attend to your education elsewhere now
get out whatever man that sounds pretty
good to me
huh I'll take that offer I don't have to
do you have been expelled
what that [ __ ] what the [ __ ] this is my
unlucky day and
lucky day at the same time I'm expelled
that means I can punch people how much I
like hello friends
hi how are you oh yeah yes son this
quest busting in part 1 hey Jimmy
hey day terrible honey headaches me
everybody might hate you but everybody
laughs at me yeah thank you let's start
without those kids are jerks anyway but
I tried I know I mean I tried to do the
right thing
make people happy stop all the fighting
make everyone calm down yeah now
everyone laughs at me people used to be
scared of me now I'm a joke is Gary
gonna be because now I can't deal with
the fact that that kid beats me well it
ain't over yet
got one minor setback and you're acting
like a baby yeah pathetic I've been
expelled they're just waiting for my
mother to come back from her 58th
honeymoon that I'm out of here
how is that a minor setback losers oh
shut up the fat dork whatever you and
your husband friend don't scare me see
even a dork like that laughs at me we
gotta prove Gary was behind everything
we don't even know if it was Gary all we
know is townie kids beat up a bunch of
Bulworth kids I mean I don't care
anymore
well we've got to find out what's going
on come on okay but if we're gonna take
on those townies we're gonna need a
bunch of backup someone big who doesn't
hate me yet Russell I'll be at his house
all right we're done all right cool this
sounds interesting what's going on pity
you don't want to come with me all right
we got to go to Russell's house
karate or something
but first we are going to get the golf
cart to the Batmobile
[ __ ] the skateboard is slow when you
have had the go card I'm really out of
the [ __ ] way out of the way move
[ __ ] get out the way get out the way
[ __ ] get up the white crew right
Jenkins got that big got come good
Russell's house what the [ __ ] am i doin
Russell's house I can't drive this
[ __ ] old car interesting Russell I
need you there we go
thankfully Evan Russell I need your help
to bust into the dropouts hideout
I'm sure Ross Ellie is in there oh yes
whoa Russell okay I see a bit of
similarity oh I get the matters vest man
okay that's fine ah Ken yeah [ __ ]
go run song go go brush off go rush up
go go Russell you will go on math know
when ma Hey Oh
everybody knew Graham it falls on three
one two three one two three one two
three
nipple Russell depo muffled listening
about it
Russell go run go go go out you [ __ ]
arse off don't you death don't respect
my no need nine nine huh I didn't do
anything all right sorry brothers but
before I take the quest I want to do
this jump there we go Geronimo whoa
Marilyn nailed it all right let's accept
the Russell quest again
Russell is such a good actor only ever
I'll catch a death Drive
there we go Russell Yammer ah I'm
getting so sick of traveling in this
game honestly I finally Jesus they're
locked
oh and back Russell you're crazy bro
he's [ __ ] out of his mind
busting and pi2 you crazy Russell yeah
indeed one this doesn't look so good I
don't way what the [ __ ] alright well as
lessee a helped me break in I was
together with the burps I don't even
know
I wasn't he technically wasn't me I was
I was at Russell Oh we'll see about that
reset the generator switches restore the
power [ __ ] [ __ ] and and gain
dead end where are awesome rats I'm a
sale I myself I'm a sales I don't know
why I have to crawl under that but hey
I'm doing it fine gee why okay sure
whatever you say go whatever you're
saying it's okay with me
I am that guy even though it's okay to
be guy
when my that's helped for a shame to
notice and say ah [ __ ] he doesn't have a
[ __ ] cricket the game is really
really flawed but hey it's still awesome
you can't go really comes later oh no
not Omar anyone by Omar all right let's
just [ __ ] him up
I finally did it indeed Jake's disguise
this guy is a lot of Defense's yes I can
I got Russell Rasta go Rasha Rasha go
rush away baby
hubba hubba does anyone say that anymore
hubba hubba you see a girl nope that's
not gonna way you got to look at them
and if the eyes and be like
that's really all you got there that's
all I did pretty much how did I get
there on side of your lane your kind
around
oh you're racist you're racist oh [ __ ]
doesn't do any damage
[ __ ] here's a lot of Health Bam Bam Bam
Bam bang there we go whoo I got a key
car now on flaking [ __ ] chemical
plants hell is going on in this quest
Sasha chemical plant for at what what am
i doing
bowels tell me man you don't know which
button to press [ __ ] press all of
them no no no I gotta take stairs
what's that [ __ ]
we're out there what the [ __ ] what I'm a
seal [ __ ] Sam I said you don't
expect me to be a sail look at my butt I
don't have a bust
it's like all big one big thing it's
wonderful
no what are you doing Jimmy oh no get up
oh my god that's a what an epic action
scene to finish this game up how about
that bet you weren't expecting that were
wonderful
now where the [ __ ] did we go okay now I
can go so confused right now my brain is
like huh huh oh the [ __ ] pipe trick
again I want a pipe wrap the pipes walls
hey I can have pipes too far they're
both epic high tidal yo shall not pass
I don't even know who you are but hey
your leg
no I like there all right one more
to hell up finish hair come on big guy
baby he's a good idea no no no oh good
that's what I thought dang now what made
you think it was a good idea in the
first place
Gary man I hate that school yeah Ed's
couldn't afford to send me there and now
I'm stuck in this dump of a town Gary
said we make them all pay wait a second
yeah Gary that backstabbing two-faced
sociopath put you up to this
ah I bet he said the two of then really
as a rival or some Cray how'd you know
he told me the same garbage didn't do me
any good either come on you're gonna
help me make him pay for his lies yeah
bye-bye killing him hopefully you know
you're all right Jimmy I know I'm
awesome okay see you I just broke into
his house that nonsense dope and I beat
his ass but I'm alright I'm alright
you hear that breasts I'm alright kids
ain't so bad after all you know once you
take him out get him boost up and then
fed up with food he's not so bad at all
oh I can just save here I forgot about
that cool I forgot about that I forgot
about that
got that I forgot about that oh all
right breasts gonna have this episode
here lack of papers enjoy subscribe
don't become about today and I'll see
you next episode oh my god